hey everyone welcome to cooking with
kylo huh kylo Ren I am about to have a
Star Wars party and so my friends are
gonna be coming over so they're probably
make a cameo here partway through the
video but I got this costume at the
Disney Store it is a child's size 9 like
for a 9 year old it's very tight I
currently am NOT able to breathe that's
okay
you're gonna make a stormtrooper cake
today I'm gonna try okay let's do this
preheat oven uh combine cake mix I need
a bowl got our bowl our lightsaber put
that down
whole egg recipe egg white recipe thanks
egg white a point so like kylo Ren would
definitely do egg whites
definitely there's no convenient place
to put a microphone on my kite and Ren
costume I had gloves that go with this
but I'm gonna wait but those on after
we're done doing our egg whites how many
was that
that was three forgot to close the
fridge hi Jenn hey welcome to Pylos
kitchen sweet oh I got stuck in it I
think it's a captain 500 on the dew is
it like so it is yes yeah but that mask
do not look like a perv as a mud mask
well I can I got stuck in the costume so
now I have my costume is here down there
slide one in 1/4 cup water 1 in 1/4 cup
water
I'm actually trying to make this edible
1/4 1/2 cup oil this one oil 1/2 cup 1/2
cup that looks about that looks about
1/2 cup to me beat with mixer we don't
have a mixer and I'm not going to use a
blender because I'm I'm too lazy things
are going well ok now we're gonna beat
it beat it beat it I feel like
something's not right
it just seems a little runny who needs a
mixer or a blender when I have an arm
this is real runny one 1/4 water 1/2 cup
oil 4 egg whites 1 2 3 4 is this what
just what batter looks like for cake I
think it does yeah
I will give it my blessing maybe I'll do
it in this round pan so it'll look like
a stormtrooper head what do you guys
think I think it's a great idea I'm in a
hurry because I know everyone's gonna
get here and I'm gonna be cooking I was
supposed to make this cake 3 hours ago
2016 is gonna be wild wild wild actually
that's a lot more than I thought I'll
just put the rest in here
do you have a spatula or spatula must be
at your low it's gonna be pretty high I
feel like do you have a special me I'm
gonna be talking I don't listen
this one isn't open I just bought it
this is going to be a very very very
very tiny bundt cake
our ask you about one more all right
the cakes look like they're ready I mean
I'm just gonna have to keep checking on
and really is what the so what's gonna
happen and hope for the best
gosh hope I don't catch my cape on fire
so these are gonna cook bake whatever
and I'm gonna get an Instagram photo of
Kyllo cooking Oh
the cakes are done one cake oh gosh
hallelujah I think that our friends are
here to make these cookies how do I do
that
that's much work all right we're back
here at the party has officially started
JP got a who is Vivi a pinata you've got
so many party supplies it was incredible
I'm gonna start by raiding store anymore
no promises that any of this is gonna
work out well I mean it's not actually
shaped like stormtroopers is gonna be
stormtrooper inspired oh yes miss no
minions okay so first things first we're
gonna ice the cake are you trying to
what are you boo who are you you're like
kylo Ren with a stormtrooper all right
Star Wars PD attending my class you all
right time to decorate you know what I
think is too much icing under God this
looks good already water oh I didn't
even look up at you okay good I have a
taste
not yet yeah finish the minion cake
don't abuse
we can't it's copy written I now need to
zoom in so I can film the making of lead
we can do it
okay here's the cake I'm unsure anything
about anything it's a storm pure birth
inspired inspired by the film inspired
by this one's your birth released in
what do you think released in theatres
oh I think I'm gonna make this a bb-8 or
not only as an r2d2 I'll be fired
why don't you make it into a Finn
I'm just gonna do this he it's fine
there you go
looks just like our to meet you fire
inspired by the film he was driven no I
want you to keep making that that looks
just fine spinning is gonna be so awful
to edit this is such a good time we're
using Final Cut Pro 7 I will be using 10
do you like it it's inspired by a little
form it's inspired by the film it looks
like a minion
I love these movies Universal property
Universal property I'd like to show them
wait why don't you do it this is r2d2
inspired by the film
no I'll put another dot this is good I
quit
thank you guys so much for watching I'm
sorry this is a hot mess but what else
would you expect from my channel
kylo cooking out this is cooking with
kylo so do you find kylo Ren yeah you
need a thumbnail for it I gotta take
this off because I can't breathe this is
a child's costume hey everyone happy new
year today it is a depending upon when
you watch this today is the first day of
2016